this is a great cookie to have around in
the holidays you know it just kind of
makes everybody think about like cozy
warm fires and
holiday family gatherings my name is
elizabeth belkin i am the executive
pastry chef and co-owner of cake monkey
bakery in los angeles and today i'll be
making our very famous little merry
cookie definitely important to use
pastry flour as opposed to all purpose
flour it has a lot less gluten and it
will give you a finer
texture and a lighter feel when we first
started working with this we wanted to
make something that was reminiscent of
an oatmeal cream pie but that was like
definitely a little bit more
sophisticated and still to this day i'm
amazed how sweet the cookie is but like
how delicious anyway and how popular it
is and it's really a cookie that adults
and kids love my little boy loves it
he's not a chocolate fan so it's a great
cookie to have out there for people who
don't want chocolate chip cookie or
something like that i would eat it on
its own and it's actually excellent
frozen i have to say like it's really
good that way they're also great for
parties we make small versions of them
that you can just take two bites of and
walk away so initially when i was making
the oatmeal cookies they were coming out
like very thick and dense when i was
developing the recipe i was amazed how
much sugar and how much butter i had to
put into it so that they would actually
like just hit the oven and spread like a
pancake like right away and not bake
like a chocolate chip cookie you know
that's like thicker so the reason why
i combine the baking soda with boiling
water before adding it to the dough is
because most baking sodas are what's
called double acting that would mean it
reacts initially to liquid and then
again to heat if you're trying to
bake a cookie that's flat and lacy you
want to kind of remove a little of the
oomph of the leavener it's super
important to chill the dough because if
you use the dough right after you've
made it you're going to end up with just
a mess on your tray like it won't hold
any kind of a shape a key to a good
butter cream is starting with room
temperature butter you take the time to
cream it on its own first before you
start adding other ingredients to it and
in this case when you're making a maple
buttercream i strongly suggest buying
real maple it gives it like a very rich
molasses
sweetness it's delicious as opposed to
just like syrupy sweet maple syrup i
think people are surprised by the maple
in the filling like they think old
oatmeal cream pie and then they take a
bite of it and they're like oh this is
different
so it's important to note that in the
recipe i've called for pre-sifted
powdered sugar and what i mean by that
is to sift it and then measure the
amount of sugar that you're going to use
if you measure two cups of unsifted
powdered sugar it's almost double the
amount of sugar so be careful about that
and also sifting helps you to easily
incorporate the sugar into the butter
so now that the dough has chilled we're
going to go ahead and scoop these with a
three-quarter tablespoon size scoop once
you've arranged them on the tray be sure
to allow some space between each cookie
i would say about three inches between
this cookie because they'll spread to
encourage that spreading what you're
going to do is wet your fingertips with
a little bit of water and tap them down
until they're about a quarter of an inch
thick before you pipe the buttercream
into the cookies make sure the cookie is
cooled completely i've put the maple
buttercream in a piping bag with a half
inch tip and then once you place the top
cookie on there you'll press it down a
little bit so it'll squish towards the
edges the cookie is crunchy on the edges
and then very chewy and soft in the
center and super creamy
oh my gosh i don't know if i have work i
love this thing
oh yes
[Music]
you